[Music]
I know that I have greenery too solid
for your if you were in my head
you would see that I am my team tonight
this is not a show that you will
see this is an experience you will
living like that hurts and also possesses
we don't lack ambition that
's taxes that we dream of a great
fantastic film
[Music]
need to create new machines to
develop otherwise Japanese cinema
entered my life the  things are so
different do you realize
the importance of what we are
about to find an understanding the
students aurélie
[Music]
truth has sounded
are they were more confused strangers
try something
we are saved
m
[Music] this
is the end
j
the paper
[Music]
[Applause]
and this ordinary
[Music]